[Música]
8 millones de personas siguen bajo
alerta climática en el estado
estadounidense de California que
continúa enfrentando el llamado río
atmosférico un fenómeno que ha generado
Fuertes lluvias e inundaciones desde
diciembre pasado
miles de trabajadores públicos marcharon
en diversas ciudades de Venezuela para
exigir aumentos salariales y mejoras
laborales los empleados aseguran que Los
sueldos no alcanzan siquiera para la
canasta básica
todo listo para el inicio del esperado
juicio contra Genaro García Luna jefe de
seguridad Nacional de México durante el
gobierno de Felipe Calderón el ex
funcionario está acusado de narcotráfico
y vínculos con el cartel de Sinaloa
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos Porque después de meses
de sequía el estado de California hace
frente a un fenómeno conocido como río
atmosférico que ha provocado
torrenciales lluvias en la zona lo que
ha causado inundaciones y un sinnúmero
de daños materiales se espera que las
condiciones mejoren en los próximos días
California se mantiene en alerta máxima
millones de personas han sido afectadas
por las lluvias torrenciales vientos
feroces y fuertes inundaciones que
afectan al Estado desde Navidad por un
fenómeno conocido como río atmosférico
es decir una franja de humedad que
transporta grandes cantidades de agua de
los trópicos
estamos viendo que este tipo de cosas
ocurren con más frecuencia ahora con el
crecimiento de los incendios y el
aumento de las temperaturas del océano
tenemos mucha más humedad en el aire
después de los incendios que fueron
severos aunque los pronósticos indican
que las condiciones mejorarán al
finalizar la semana alrededor de 8
millones de personas permanecen bajo
alerta de inundación en todo el estado
según el servicio geológico de
California se han sufrido más de 400
deslizamientos de Tierra desde el 30 de
diciembre y los vientos violentos han
derribado miles de árboles además de
causar constantes cortes de energía
provocar daños a residencias y dejar
ciudades enteras bajo el agua
recientemente el Gobierno Federal hizo
una declaración de emergencia y prometió
ayudas a los californianos
el presidente Joe biden declaró que
existe un gran desastre en el estado de
California y ordenó ayuda Federal para
complementar los esfuerzos de
recuperación estatales y locales este
fenómeno no había sido visto en
California en décadas un estado que
normalmente es afectado por fuertes
sequías e incendios forestales
característicos de su clima seco vamos
ahora a Venezuela donde las protestas de
trabajadores públicos cumplieron una
semana iniciaron los profesores pero ya
se han Unido otros sectores que piden
una alzan los salarios y una mejora en
las condiciones laborales aseguran que
lo que ganan actualmente no alcanza ni
siquiera para la canasta básica Daniela
Zambrano corresponsal de France 24 en
Caracas nos explicó más de las demandas
de los trabajadores y las posibilidades
reales que tienen de ser escuchados por
el gobierno
en esta oportunidad los trabajadores
públicos principalmente el gremio de
maestros pidió de un plazo hasta el
jueves para que las autoridades se
pronuncien y respondan a sus demandas o
de lo contrario continuarían las
protestas Cuáles son estas demandas ya
lo decían ustedes básicamente es la
homologación de los salarios a la
canasta básica para poner en contexto a
la audiencia en el mes de noviembre la
canasta básica según en la federación
venezolana de maestros se ubica en 474
dólares al mes de enero el salario
mínimo promedio no llega a los siete
dólares por eso es que estos
trabajadores han salido a protestar Ya
llevan una semana de manera consecutiva
pero realmente son protestas que llevan
meses y hasta años tanto el sector salud
como el transporte como los educadores
porque mientras no haya cambios en el
materia económica cambios estructurales
un simple aumento de salario no serviría
porque inmediatamente la inflación
pulverizaría esos salarios en esta
oportunidad la manifestación en Caracas
iba a ser frente al Ministerio de
Educación sin embargo el gobierno acercó
los alrededores y los trabajadores
cambiaron el rumbo de esta manifestación
a una plaza a otra plaza en el centro de
Caracas pero realmente hubo protestas en
al menos diecinueve estados del país
porque estas exigencias como lo venía
diciendo son por parte de todos los
trabajadores públicos Colombia sigue
siendo el principal productor mundial de
hoja de Coca la materia primordial para
la producción de cocaína de acuerdo con
la ONU y los cultivos ilícitos
incrementaron un 43% en el año 2021 una
cifra récord el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro ha reiterado el fracaso el
fracaso de la política antidrogas y de
la prohibición que impulsaron gobiernos
anteriores
limítrofe con Venezuela el catatumbo
alberga la mayor superficie de cultivo
ilegal de coca en el mundo José del
Carmen abril es uno de los cientos de
miles de personas que abandonaron la
agricultura tradicional para cultivar
estas hojas verdes la coca para los
campesinos desde el 86 para acá se
convirtió en el gobierno que nunca ha
venido por acá y ustedes preguntarán por
qué o el gobierno pregunta por qué Por
qué la coca es con la que se ha llevado
a ser escuelas hacer puestos de salud
carreteras hacer la vivienda en el país
que más produce la pasta que sirve para
el polvo blanco que consumen en Estados
Unidos y Europa los recolectores son El
eslabón más débil de la cadena el
presidente izquierdista Gustavo Petro
dijo que era cambiar la política
antidrogas a nivel nacional e
internacional pero los campesinos
cocaleros piden todavía más apoyo para
la transición a otras economías y menos
criminalización varias oportunidades por
ser recolector de Coca nos nos tildan de
guerrilleros de narcotraficantes de
bueno de ser un delincuente aquí en
Colombia el gobierno nos persigue muchas
veces nos han llevado presos en
diciembre del gobierno se comprometió a
dejar de perseguir a los campesinos con
menos de dos hectáreas de coca y la
semana pasada la Policía Nacional fijó
su meta de erradicación de cultivos
ilícitos para 2023 en 20 mil hectáreas
una reducción de 60% con respecto al
objetivo para 2022 las autoridades
buscarán este año atacar los eslabones
más lucrativos del negocio y luchar
contra la violencia recrudecida por Las
Guerras entre grupos armados y
narcotraficantes
y para seguir con temas de política
antidrogas Este martes inicia en Estados
Unidos y el juicio contra Genaro García
Luna máximo responsable de la seguridad
pública durante el gobierno de Felipe
Calderón en México el ex funcionario
está acusado de narcotráfico y de
aceptar sobornos del Cartel De Sinaloa
cambio de facilitar la operación del
grupo hablamos previamente con peniley
Ramírez periodista y escritora quien nos
explicó como García Luna trabajo en el
gobierno mexicano teniendo vínculos con
la DEA pero al mismo tiempo con el
cartel de Sinaloa
bueno ocurrió durante más de una década
y parte de eso es de lo que queremos
descubrir en el en el juicio a ver
básicamente lo que el juicio va a
permitir es también hacernos una
pregunta muy importante acerca de cómo
Estados Unidos Elige a sus aliados en la
región en América Latina no es la
primera vez que una persona en quien el
gobierno de Estados Unidos ha confiado
termina siendo cuestionado o investigado
por corrupción Y también vamos a poder
saber más acerca de cómo existían estas
colaboraciones y un poco Por qué hay un
fracaso que se ve en los números de la
guerra contra el narcos y la misma
persona que estaba encargada de evitar
que las drogas llegaran a Estados Unidos
era si según esta acusación la misma
persona que al mismo tiempo estaba
ayudando al cartel de Sinaloa
la organización Internacional del
trabajo público un informe donde apunta
que factores como la guerra en Ucrania y
la lenta recuperación económica tras la
pandemia causarán que el empleo mundial
apenas crezca un uno por ciento en 2023
y un panorama similar para 2024
América Latina se enfrenta a un 2023 con
dificultades en materia de empleo un
informe publicado por la organización
Internacional del trabajo Indicó que en
este 2023 el crecimiento laboral se
estancará luego del impulso tomado en la
post pandemia
la entidad estima que latinoamérica
solamente crecerá un 0,9% mientras que
en América del Norte no habrá incremento
e incluso el desempleo repuntará en
France 24 el analista Daniel lacalle
explicó los motivos de estas previsiones
por lo que significa fundamentalmente es
que América Latina no solamente se está
empobreciendo sino que está perdiendo
muchos pasos con respecto al crecimiento
global la oit remarcó que uno de los
grandes inconvenientes afrontar es el
constante aumento del empleo informal la
desaceleración obligaría a muchos a
aceptar condiciones laborales más
precarias la organización subrayó que la
calidad de los puestos de trabajo sigue
siendo una preocupación fundamental
porque deja a muchas personas
imposibilitadas de acceder a mecanismo
de protección social en América Latina
donde la informalidad supera el 53%, el
deterioro económico general potenciar
estos déficits entre otros efectos
negativos el informe también expuso una
disparidad entre hombres y mujeres en el
último año ciento de la población activa
masculina estuvo ocupada mientras que la
femenina apenas rondó al 46% claramente
Hay un problema de
constantes trabas a la inversión y
además Hay un problema cultural de
la idea generalizada de que las tareas
domésticas tienen que recaer en las
mujeres el nuevo año le plantearé
engorrosos desafíos a una región que ya
ha padecido en 2022 con desaceleraciones
y alta inflación fin del informativo
volvemos en breve
[Música]